[Music]
where
and
[Music]
I'm going to get married
the subject
that wouldn't have disavowed made load
introduction of the landscape
and
yet
in plastic
start with m
what we see here at 25 the load of
products called foot ice cream
and therefore  we have it in production units
including what we call
production sauces and we are about to
deliver to customers so
dehydration flap and bottles have been
stolen if in
what we do it is only in English to  an
area of customers others relating to a sauce
we're going to try to deliver to our custo
ers it's not bad at this source there we he
r that charlie who says a contr
ct system that you still have to know when
o smell this on the customer's  is not
a girl at all will tell me it's
really black to know it's how
to do it so we felt that I
'm going
and later
during this time this involvement in the
sauce we can have a delegation  of
the initial plan by jeans woven between countries -
diana risk of pass  er at the customer and
therefore it will be helped our mental deficiencies
the liquid continues need or vegas and
if we produce more there will be a
storage energy space nas compass and
the square of castres keynes and the
temperature so
we have the quantity  cannot change
in huge simply endowed his
part-time
the lows are destitute
so necessarily that it is necessary to be able to
predict
when you had arrived only documented
if not possible to know how to manage if
really pl used in this sense
concern customers see it is a
little contact from Laval if we move on to the
next one
and so that's more how we
define the youth fund in the framework of
bright confidence
so currently via a model
which makes it possible to predict that a valve
contains it from the road and the demand
for  the week of a century and so this
is the
means of reflection prediction will have the
room it only has only one ball
has so we are going very well that even if we
feed possible decision but it is not
no common sense and we have all the time and
the institute our from the center says - and so
it doesn't really like the operations
have first of your bulletin more and
more complicated on the radio satisfies the
class positions bus at  have style
and on the uncertainty that goes with it in the
sco has you not become c
given the history of the transformation
of the destruction of customers came
relating to customers likewise and also
contextual data data
relating to  the nationality
is what provided the confidence that there
are two russian museum currencies tone
i was talking about vampire operating his debt
is represented by operations there
in first model i produced he
simply has someone stimulate his
recovery  when he leaves to rely
on his instinct to provide
prediction apparatus but without any guarantee
without liking him very stupid it will give in
talk about it is a trio to find out how it
is there are several fields which I have
already spoken about  in futsal and to nature
during your and if one passes for style
following
therefore the objectives
his sticks and credit on the other hand to
this match very skeptical to are the
requests of the customers based on
really manageable history and in
now quantifying uncertainty
that is linked to his predictions there here we
look at a few more traits of the
passat that was delivered in confidence
version since when you mentioned it
also an off mode
before initiating from the east  has just tipped over
in the current crisis and customer data
your group's sensitive success
of not
really had to wait for innovation and
digital transformation
guarantee at the news counter
so it got heated question to
titled variable to three
categorical variables  which define the
configuration of the canvas bags a little so only
work with static shots this
fair in dallas we obtain
time series on this request so what
we see here  in the data that we
look at the royal target so every
every division every complaint against
a single box is seven years it is
defined by fixing this wave of the body
and which I just talked about the
back aneb so whatever we want  our
health at the request of the customers to very
well and all the other variables
well of course influenced more or less one
of them on behalf of the customers
it is an increasing number the actions where
there will be
requests these are the results  on the case
of maria at the bottom of a group influence
gave an example
[Music]
according to the elysée
finally it's
good how does it complicate
a sum that its birth but I must
say there was our monolith and therefore
economic and  imer we will say
it brews in us that we had to compensate
geographical areas or more than one
all its thefts and after
the three aggressors
as for fx we obtain a sect in
front of its growth always
understand that it is
normal
the  through which followed the
city censorship obvio
sly and if we go to the next one so wh
t we have been so the villans confi
ence was going to inherit a romance and t
quantify this article the predi
tion interval and we wish to have
he guarantee that they work well
ff n  don't just have a model
that gives in the worse
so it was the idea of the score of 7-5 6-7 eveni
g I'm free with the methods of his c
ildhood where there are very great price
of saint exupéry contributors who
have no knowledge of the heavens
is therefore of course it is seen that it is
the object of confidence that of you the
death of a dinner with the hostages I am
told that is what we are doing there but
also  what we can find in the
other action sheets which are one of the
rare states
the crisp
to present all this is 500 kg and
more work on this risk is to
know how we can
before perceived
their agreement
do not limit did not hesitate the  things
added m
i'm wasting my life lying i forgot it's  t
that this recorded workshop
now places following
I believe
on this
on this case one to
put away 3 the one who works on the
characterization of the models
was interested if fish before project 3
but there are only three who are
leaning on this raid therefore has the project because
action explains inhabited whose curious
first works made this one quality
of the time series
after there is the daughter of marc is the one
who was originally the fact that she
came with the snese
obviously invents to usefully serve the break
before
reported monitoring as
well and who is very old rector
with work and
therefore gave me the first bag for sure
evolution explains empowered evening because we were
doing work which has just read
your saint-exupéry  choice if it is
represented
but so there the idea was to
apply what again the tools that
came out to say that he worked a lot a
lot on the qualities
how to use
explains on the sacha series wings  nt that
a priori had not worked
specifically on the subject that on the
other hand they have towards its guest costs
so for the moment they are three in
Corsica and the ademe series which is that
of brand after a simpler example
the profession  like a varied multi and you
it's about
making temperature forecasts
during the principle will be a cause but
the data is a little simpler
then is the big question what does it
look like explains ability of a
decision on a size  series the sq we are
going to display his underpants and among
entries shine the four years while
in the case of martin how many elected 27
d entry there are ten more
so there are fed up and he tries
what the variables are  and if you believe that
they are the most important in the
decision-making afterwards and that will be
useful to the person skilled in the art indeed the
network has obviously understood
since indeed we know that it is
all the same  overall temperature
which will decide the
temperature friends that's what we see
on the illustration and there we see
things are clear the more they
contributed to the lézignan fund for
the
dac prediction obviously this is another example
is rather simple and that it should be
the plug for now
nothing specific for the del series to
operate i have weaved decent income
to the cars use president
tuesday in the pages of the same nature
will be more signal barriers  will
perhaps be more complicated it will be necessary I
think that we did not use the word
take back the original model
suppliers of parts have checked that
we will be able for what has
achieved complicated to visualize the
elements which make  making the decision
that in addition to having more weight in the tradition
when it is necessary to send it is another
element to ensure confidence
what to say about the advertisement, i.e. the
model has understood that it was a business
card  explain where this story comes from  re
stresses the matrix shots 4
assists and its two months it's time
before the split it's history
and cdc d'argent occultation
by
its marks and to the beatles bruce graham
henry
it's a relationship of  causality
it's correlation
yeah
it's for help for research
ajaccio the season it came very
smartly from skate
please so life
surprised you by current mutation
not only jaw conquering
hot
when his parents and my  friends
quantification of uncertainty for example
when they who used to deal
with seduction but there is also a long time
to revoke before the methods no
prediction firm tone from above there is
no hypothesis distribution functions
begin to fall  by this
type of method which will be applied on
its ambitions layer on the methods of
continuation of uncertainty which spoke
of a lethal gesture but also the most
important thing is that there are
guarantees theory of looks
should  ent
be applied for baby boy sir
only moment that he is
currently in progress in forty years of mastery
I took a short trip
instrumental powers by the basket weavers how
will the brand evolve starts not for
example looking at the windows by
the aggression
c  it is
therefore there since there are two
categories of professions that keep
for a lot in africa
goalkeeper it is normal the greatest
coverage of the elections
for a hundred thousand times
thank you I can very well his mother who is
is closed which still has all the skull
which will encompass all the points I will have
in the moment tight it is not the goal of the
blitz of havas the lte chip cover
and but while having the width of the
intervals to make it pass  the
metrics of sharp is this so whether to
join it or not these two are 20 years old
and liam title has started well in their
actions to squeeze the handset the
dairies in having a music will be
years old one of the limitations to
understand  a hypothesis this woman we
must give her back her exchange to
sadirac the boss is why at the beginning
of the insurrection had said to himself that we are going to
lower in a passionate tone
what does it give the spanking
to adapt it  of work then but we
realize that we already have good results
currently and also in the lovers
action there are sections that invest
and there is not
much internationalization moral feeling
there are reasons that push that his
fault  if my management this loan in its
grave well the reform
it is therefore rejected this
hypothesis to us go to see if it is not
established that the result which one wishes to
deliver up to 10 passes it is an
activist who will combine all the
methods Sunday morning by
sequins climate more in detail the
excellent
with so the sepaq
gold on this disc is
so in five following there will be so
an overview of
how the notes his trainer tauriel
example
it is so as I was explaining honda will
of  base lester whether it is
aggressors who predict at la rochelle
to the drifts of the stars who predict so
therefore of securitization the camps says elvia that
they arrive after ten years of
interval of prediction
and there are television levels there to
take to repeat  in production to
come on the sidelines for oneself to
square average to already have the
deviations are too much the case of his clan
when the states and in all cases
of entry guarantees on what one
obtains and therefore these two  categories
we will therefore look
where
we can take the models that have
already trained but it would be necessary to sell them
to other areas to use them for
the calibration mouknass departure from the as
written that it wants advantages since that
is how in this city  where there
we can the idea is to partition
I was coming in quarantine we can
use both but no it
helps me to
help companies
and therefore to bring it to 100 kg of
well-managed party which is  'call mabiki
no chance lets do some
applications how much in front of the 6 l for
the rest it's by the way who has big
breasts of richard albert parent
had released by this year so
taxpayers
i work on his party and so 2.5
to really see the implication the
mandale
therefore the following scene beyond these convoys
and modem of a work of conviction
without any formalization the
first model it is the model which was
provided to the project confidence crimes of
the year and  the second is another
site and backfires
in the
names we believe them and valier and therefore
as I
say meetic and meetic which will point to
the cover so there it is from Pau a
small composition launched by a  torres
what a temptation i currently want from
4% - coverage that has been provided
empirically of harmony
the second is thorny sharp
final place and it's simply don't have
the money from the average interval over
a whole series to assess  er if it can be
used we are told so these two
metrics
quickly possible we see that the first who
had formed at the beginning so the only one of the
four years makes a good sense which is
huge when will become this time my
conscience about half
but  we see that the puppet of pinon the
first it is better of the second
death the complementarity of the two
metrics is that I become only one
the nozzles thank you knee but it's just
because he increased the intervals
so it  that's why he took
it and that's really the idea you we would like to
have the critical data too and
so when we go up button
after
button the season the examples of two
models to use it also there the
bosses  formalization after so the
first one is the same as that of
thailand but with a stage of that we get
carried away ization which educates to steal 2
so we see that they had enough 14%
per cent but where we have  17 years old as the
petals and the demand she from  more
to increase the best results
that makes him so it's lyon opposite
variance destination have formalized
up to 30
4% the murderer father who has tiger
for the moment to is heading towards these
results which are quite a sight
c  it is not
possible to have the best
possible measurement tools
on the docks to want to bring the
best is therefore between the three
warned and that it is not the Romans this moment
we have a tool me indeed and
because  cali a little coffee or a little
pepper so it's going to be excellent well
fortunately for not pouring the process
made it work say I see a
measuring tool that has just been
meyer qualified and the fact that I did everything
[Music]
for  eric the interests
I was taking from bonn who had
just said it's that if we salute through
the dances between these two over
time
yes this money there
it therefore goes to distribute it is a
tool which has developed the cea which  is
more of a framework for developing  s
machine learning systems and in
particular among all among all the
tools provided this framework has
monitoring tools and therefore in
this case if they have done it it is
that ten have implemented almost the
mastery that it does  the more than one who
comes to present brands in their
monitoring tools or voice ambition
on the region that may look like
worn-out formula
we find in martizay cellar it is
allowed different music to evaluate
evening ball and precision below
this one group of  evaluation
how on this revision check
performance and then if not it
is above it is as one evaluates the quality
of the confidence interval that it
provides with the finds roughly the
forms of the approach but it is to
redo its  laces which will have to integrate
so we see the central vision displays
5 which measures and the son who uses it
to make a monitoring tool and on
the transparency after sending
the video if you can launch it so there we
will see that this tool in real time it
will evaluate the character measurements
presented on Tuesday
and then to say the quality
to the radio questions we want to
help you it is all the less
spectacular were an example there was
not any  went well
so the video to see
m panther remain because here we are
handling something that is going
well the way to keep
their occurrence for the moment it is going
well because forecast remains consistent and
therefore and we remain  well at the expense
of the spaces of in the
expected boarding schools you see well that in the
monitor and well what we are going to do is
that since mark has calculated an interval
of a circle in which it is necessary to guarantee
that we are going to  hold the monitoring is
able to use this term of innovation
comes out of this interval and whether
something is happening normal
operating system was at that time
ray entails with silk cod is
that
it is  that we are going to use is this
interva  The prediction is detected that
when you come out of it
as I was I would like only one
game but it works too well
installation of
one again you to hide
it is also one of the famous tales with the
uk c  is that we can also yungas which
are logical
yes
following
by
changing the
subject euthanasia
if you remember
recall were two
successes which
games to present to you two
the initiation of projects which are
vestal
first subject it is  this one wanted
I didn't work it's a colleague
who worked on this subject in the regions
so there
it goes since last night the
explanations I'm so
broken on his saddle so that I could
the emotion  attack opponent bbc
possibility of deceiving model take
all over the media
here simply a small message although
a run into a new attack of a
good defense
in recent years and little by little has
discarded the idea of generating a defense that is 1
hen
7-7 certified  iés and therefore we like it with
big ears
thank you
and therefore
a sentence
the idea is precisely of 80 reality which
are his
then to
work on the distribution resulting from the
reduction in this zone is disturbed what
we can say for example  is
that according to the
distribution of the aco his
used to disturb the guys there but
well from the production of the model it
seems more in a bag than normal and
that it can be interesting to go
easter because as  his feet
here in adana
if we assimilate an attack precisely a
disturbance you between these
2,205 in Arabic finally to guarantee
our edition of the model nor often on
this Internet user what that means is that
obviously an attack as
important and which does not  does not look like up there at
all
is a deceiver and me not
excellent we leave the collection certified
here if we pass the next two 6
so uses
I
toc
and there we end up with a model that
makes Morocco [ __ ]  rd the observations
of merville in addition this following year
to the annual production which will
necessarily be exceptional in this case
but it is an election is the question
then it is that of how I
mentioned scintillating disturbed
coming to disturb the input data  here
who are for example displaying the
paris bordeaux campaigns it was perfect
she is disturbed to be able
precisely 20 species two men of
tradition certified for the mac what that
means in practice it is opposite to the
next scene is that  a person
attacked by disrupting
rooted domains in this case didn't say it if
you don't have it the idiots because that's what they've
been shown to
use by network when you see
that red line that doesn't seem to me  not at
all okay
while the disturbance is small
do we also see his two
houses vignoboul between the
ten-year interruption
certified and finally thanks to the radios
is missing
find a collection
thank you we v  to find a tradition that
returns to this area to certify
the augusts in the face of small attacks a
small comment the ifi of rents it is
a certification on the prediction
for an attack which was difficult
not even
sufficiently small
but on the other hand that does not tell me  nothing on the
quality of this certification the
model exactly on the other hand servat no perfume
it can be very good as it will fall
it's because I'm interested
and
to get it out messages
on all this
work is done it's  by the
disturbances of the sky my friend of
possible tracks with working on
beds
disturbance tool
this understanding 2
yes that's it that it was work
but this time mills money and
clothes
it's rather a savannah the  action sheet
stop I was able to work
everyone is in these stages but
in the awareness of uncertainty
but this time by ied how to
use and generative models
to explain we see that  can be
useful which is generative models
from simple examples of the
regulation
read squared distance between the
prediction and
and
gets
right boobs with in blue he gave the
observations and then there is in
reduction
mom what interests us it  is what
we can say about the distance between the
prediction is
there
we
can decompose this uncertainty into
two components the first novelty
makes two model houses on the
model of aude and the message passes
enough its rebirth man it is enough
to  'improve from it for more
parameters
present in the meat we are
also interested in medications it's
tintin results in a framework of action sheets
because I don't have time to show
here
use as soon as possible by the
uncertainties  on the data as the
sexual simple are quite simple during
their advising of data concerning
this certainty because if he gave
you use seems relevant
sufficiently relevant has  u can
correctly form a prediction you
are a little thought on the other hand it still
hurts well having a safe city
this uncertainty is slow comes to 7
against here for example where I
simply change the deal between
or use it ugolin interesting  like
a sonata the cardio a column that
is not very effective and yes four
editions and the bad ones for the cepej
question of model used a
super smart model of the elections otherwise
that the case his death is the dance certainty
is this a participant
this
that we can do a fairly simple thing
we can do it's supposed to be breathless and
already the classic question we can
assume
Gaussian distribution
and that's what you see here
says envelope
imagine apple store the opeeci
and
so I make let's assume this
distribution  rising yesterday in two
networks not only to predict the
mean but also the variance
to train that it can be a network
fit for art as well as to all this  that you
hover it's simply the lost had
clearly different and for
people who are not necessarily
accustomed to dealing with
league 2 immigration and who simply rents on
the a6 building next to the equation here it
lacks that if you  don't care
about variance actually
brood relief if you n go
and minimizing the
here simply to end on this
friday
here for example not lose two
dependent values and has repaired netwo
k the mean and variance can also
e postu
ated in  mixture of his on this
kind of finally with what is
called a mister did not indicate
by bishop recently would have seen
you cry points to an artifice and strikes a
man knew bottle lydiane the
beautiful
quite quickly but everywhere are
able to make destination density
conditional since we are well we
can do it but conditional on the
other hand estimates quoted
here I can do that
so from Tuesday his volley that  i learn
water distribution when mum the
distribution of
the data and so what i can
generate these advocating variables
from the input data i can generate
probable points of consumption
itself so not so for a gala
with the  episode what can do it
seems pretty bad y it can be a
country called the smile face with eyes
closed yesterday
facing the generation of young working people
i feel them
awesome
knowing the data entered i am
able to calculate the distribution of the
data  output by definition in
generate embarrassed at points in the same
way as sega ourselves in all -
talent of the normals the locks who
would be able to do this kind of
work such attempts are
precisely after the distribution
of imagery to generate images while  simply
particular points
because the theatrical
release requires that the
input data I know how to say that it
is the essence distribution
well understood it is to take
pretty good examples we learn in
the distribution of these points we
could generate output liquid
gas production estimation courses
to remember the customers
generated groups
a city where virtual curve of need
yeah that's it c  it's this
generative aspect that's that of the small narrative
that in general it's him who
receives sampling for
example it still burns me the
minimization data I know
model
also generates
championship sentences and the aspect estimates
density that  has a very subtle taste which
was then his mastery really
master to have a representation
of production needs closest to
funds could have taken place the months
the previous years here we will
check that
only one thing is that in what  I say
sorry kombat comes back to being called
rare orange and
the uncertainty on the deal is a bit it
will not improve the reduction of these
gatherings estimated
prudemm  ent by me will throw
random martin from these sands the grannies to the
victory which is irreducible but
what you were saying earlier that it was
now I think this block a
relevant question knows very well that
in life in the
how  refill amenities and
random part to hope and 100 m
neymar is so that's more an
estimate of this random
part the track part and mig have
few series the challenge
list and random part it's not
just the city already it's  is not the
head
in france we left random because
we translated something from a
maximum level of
the cemac to the qualifications in fact
you play yourself of course all and that
leads we went until capable
of certainty  that the models in
2006 to what we will use an end to
the world wars or so the second
because my wife and we could invite
people to be here I can tell you that
it's good there I'm not so all that  is
closed
the deal is me  best in koufa reduction
I tried to be quick on
the library of words but I let it be
understood
tel
it's our way of seeing things we
were also tired of you
if we find the idea it's to see
these  conditions
that my father gave me for example with the
king's monitor what it gives on the
internet continues the deaths of mark oman
interesting to know
the deaths not
random distribution which is possible
it's my brother minutes
it's a kind of terminal  we are going to take
stock of the actions
to end, however, this is a
concrete example of this
one gives it and expresses that if it is bleached
it is the way to create plague we
saw no regrets
corresponds to
thank you and long live
so yes if that  you are interested in a
certainty I think everyone
knows to appease more about the world and
talk about it than about others
ok when their mas gone pass
now
the project hailed on everything that is there
france visualization a small
visualization
loaded  d  e this presentation
here is
therefore me I presented to you to do
work in the time between on project 5
its flow the ai earlier it
is perhaps not to attend the
presentation of floral
camille who will be targeted this
session cycling
realization with 10 on a part which
is data discovery and then afterwards
when you will have models also it is
to compare the own models compared
the performances and to look at two
if we avoid this first
part so it is therefore a  tool the marbles
friend which was created by
t systems x which already allows to discover
the data and did it quickly we
see the pouts of the quit so on the
left we see that there were 29
primary modalities that we were like
production areas it may not be
that but in any case this screaming need
and the models everything and minimized and
there was little barbaric 16
secondary modalities that we see on the right
are now here below that
correspond to them  also o  nt interpreted
to events like holidays or
the right thing but maybe that's it
in any log discovered
data in also so there are the
widgets when lets you
see the categories
because when caps there also
for  get an idea of what the d
ta looks like so there it's just a block of po
nts with the t
sorted by modalities on the state of the noise
we can clearly see that there are nine vt and t
en still there
now we close a sort by  acco
to methods we watch this camp is
divided training into testing and training
the most beautiful reds c
training offices without testing at least tv our
series in September and that we no longer have
the start of a scenic are every year
as in  enter and the rest is pending
and then now we are going to move on to
another stage so therefore given up budget there a
palace of widgets are available are
from emilie surely we will add more
then to go and see the
very very nice functionalities each budget  there's a
function that allows you to do filtering
and you'll see how
the meals are used, for example we want
we may want to show
[Music]
result the different models
according to the good ideas and according
to its models in this case  and the
three models that have been tested and we are
going to use this mat chage has
filled it as filtering you will see we are
going to
activate
a filtering functionality here is there
in addition to encryption is now
that the practical encryption which allows you to
select
graphically it is all that we
want what is displayed on these nine on
this graph and then there is a widget
which allows to display therefore the brande
kits and confidence intervals
therefore
the lower limit and the upper limit of the
intervals of  trust on for
several models and I'm alive
too
so for now yes
so excuse me it's me or it's
not models
prediction models that go back
1 ter  there is confidence so there is the one in the
middle it is
quite basic where we varied this ballet
then we apply on the whole of the
model had as long as that of the others
this is what we presented to us
earlier on
Tuesday
for  improve to improve its
traditions
then also what we can display its
in the air there were interesting indicators
so presented the charter is this corn 26
city of beuvrages so there we
show you how
we can climb we can
display the charter  isn't it therefore the
charter is its lake and its
virtual barriers in charnay sellal is elaborated by
voting on the petition -
so we created becomes a
virtual variable it's top bottom
saint-alexis and you'll see at the bottom
of the  file we will do it
if I had statistics and what is
interesting is that we will see your plan
the chain that the displayed in different
forms we will the posters and a final
in the form of right and we see that it
is very variable according to the modalities
and there  also it is important to have
a calculation model
so in an article that they can
adapt
to the different modalities since it is
very very variable the variability of the
forecasts according to the david event
and the last last a file that  we are
going to present to you so here we have
shown you the predictions with the
confidence intervals around a
large hole it is the one that was inside
and outside the maintenance we are going to
show you this same phase i for we are
going to show you  the residues therefore
roughly expected by
subtracting the prediction from it at the interval
for limited edition rodez base of
the show is so we are going to have
classes finally launched without blinking 1-0
since we subtracted the petition and
also d  '
another way to visualize a little the
results
that it ends at but also
what is also important to see that
it is that for free it is enough to
pass the cursor we only direct that you
show 5 2 in we will be able to
select  r by cycle in the beautiful guys
we want to show and the displays
are updated interactive
so here we are on vips as we have
left when we are almost at the
end of
two
of this workshop
we have left
so here it is at 10 a.m.  what
you were doing shown by the video
I think we can pass so there remains a
few last minutes
transparent maintain
movement to make a synthesis good
as for free and skateboarding we knew of
nominal actions sign
we knew that the venerable is  for
example
a little speed which from time to time
on it but what sets a
project in motion is that
on the
yann c side of the actions of
these two opportunities in addition we will be
able to miss a little
to see how they arrived
and in  the other and that good to see
how his other potential
applications the purpose of having a pilot
when I was 10 for his
great and sense and
so that's where we come to the end term
normally 2
the workshop  this hour we love  start a
little late i think we can
take four five minutes even two
questions
then
miss me showed the fund managers
remain due to miners leading
indicators pleasure than what
he did see the method
of the  emission of certainties
is that these levels precisely in fact that
already
the appointment remains the best
so the part
[Music]
of the expected cycle which was mentioned as
kylie at the mobilization was the
best that I can take for
espionage in an edition it is not
better than the gradient the forms
questions
surrounding the
large agglomeration who have parents
someone of a feeling by the blow
well
disappointed
at the arrival adam of
goods from lyon
so it is a  tool my cold id he
has hanged himself for the moment he does not
discriminate he is just
virtualization the streaming part is
planned but on the other hand in relation to
the tool
see the complementarity
question cold yes  but it is precisely
on part of the oil lists so that
tells you visualization and suddenly it is
fed by data yes in
standardized format to give because you
give them the format which are very diverse
and the data of the data c is it  there are
models there is prediction interval
and its boxes all and gives an hour
they must be interfaced for it to
be fed game it comes from the formats
so I haven't show you everything
actually prior work
besides girls who for the  moment
les hameaux du piton which allows to
put the formats in the outfits in
the world this format which in the long term
really it should in fact in a
graphic way there too that is to say I
spent
like that
living planit to be
able to engage this type of
functionality in countries but it's
not the distance you have to
give the typology of the data as long
as classifying them in January 10 notions of
gorgon what does everything mean and
eat but yes yes a preliminary work  ble
to do on the good ones and after
phoning and also the interest of
dialysis patients on doing it 2 2
data guys but it's also
their sense by the way he won for
wise and bigard lists for the election
dominate this broadside  of action
detect biases
beyond in relation to contextual variables
by artists find in this
show offered more than that
but originally it's weird but after as
for them and to load models
we can load but finally
student results and
and make comparisons
part
1,500 and 1,100 it's very fast
widgets that exist need the
data to be loaded do a lot of
things
so
while his sympathy in
parallel carry out these chosen products
copy behind by go see  the two
seconds
we give that give confidence in them of the
modalities which is not required
dpa and there of the three models when we
speak and I use 28 years old tell him to this
blender his mission in haiti the film and  this
title especially the following
8th girl input data for which
rich age is asked for she is getting
ready apart from this mapping so
so here goes once i move the
cursor to small and i can also
selected multiple david and where  I
can models I do the big ones and
display the data corresponding to we
saw that I chose
hello
and we choose them and integrate for
the data set so it's
a very practical way to be able to
select then the  money is used
for display and we also want to use it
to create
and to that of reduced filtered to
train known practically
was quickly made up people's toys
as long as I can also add n 2
to give
all this good  because it's a little
quiet when the parallel series
categorize on the cabins here we go
schering but if it's simple you
can buy more
and there it's true to this option that
hits every time we can filter
once reminding the reset
the mediocre numbers on the mat
it is he who becomes active and who serves
as master is present to filter
the data
question or
maginot which is what you have
always considered for the sake
of improving predictions  make
harper has already
used the
transforming derricks but that is to say for
the attention of customers
and even cell of invention that in a
transformed here he is on his feet advancing their
small models
finally
the vintages
enlarge his collection from some
like because  that I knew what the
funds any other model
that he was going to remain
honest with the rectorate
but we realize
the station
sanaa five levels operations
which are much more interesting than they
say and this barely
500 billion France tries
the experience to know
such customers
so we will be that the management of abb in
caen 600 in nantes a gmail ritual
to transform them into attention
I am not s  sure
per year
the adjustment
minus
500 deaths
the philosopher element snsd m
but these young people wanted a marriage
because it's easy given her
human qualities that we have two
priorities
without token the solution how begins
in the east
the thoughtful militant
of the  banalities
thank you passion